[Music]
so this is brian callan being sad
yeah a little self-reflection so this
was him on sam tripoli's podcast right
okay
okay
all right
so it's conspiracy social deep water i
don't know whatever it's one of those
you know i swear to god there's there's
if there's there's a warehouse
somewhere in la that has a bunch of sets
like this but you know the cam girls
like if you go to those to the cam girl
places where it's just a bunch of
different sets of cam girls yeah it's
like this
but for la comics podcast
that or like like you ever go to a trade
show and they have all the booths yes
yes have a warehouse just set up with
all these booths
it feels like if you were to pan back
it would just be a bunch of different
different sets for a different la comic
podcast somebody should make that video
where you take this clip of calan and
tripoli talking
and then pan out
but pan out and then just keep adding
the sets from other shows yeah as you're
zooming out i'm telling you
um
like you pan out like remember the end
of the indiana jones movie where all the
bo well the boxes like the ark of the
covenant it's just exactly yeah
sam about like this community called the
comic community the comedy community huh
the one that we were making fun of and
you were yelling at us and defending do
you mean none of those guys had your
back hey brian i want to say something
right now and this is something you
could look up and look up our old videos
you know who did have your back you know
who didn't believe you us that it didn't
believe new york times us because we
were like these people and by the way
even though you said very mean things
about us yeah you said we didn't play
organized sports you said we don't crush
[ __ ] crush
uh i was terrible on the basketball team
i was terrible in little league okay i
was uh
actually not a very bad wrestler in jv
and but
pretty bad but i played sports and then
he said we didn't crush puss
we crushed it at bowling by the way but
you want to say we play sports you
should have seen us bowling we were
great
was the thing to behold
and
after all that all your friends
abandoned you and we came on the show
remember you remember the show merch we
came out and we go these [ __ ] are
lying he didn't rape anybody
and then we found one of those [ __ ]
doing stand-up at a [ __ ] theater
remember that remember that but we don't
count because we're not your cool la
friends
maybe next time maybe don't throw chris
deleo under the bus all these other guys
and hollywood what really bummed me out
and you are such an exception and i'll
always be indebted to you well because
you're on the show i get it is how um
and and by the way what about brendan
does he mention brendan
no because brendan i thought brandon was
an exception i thought they were boy b
b's boy it became the fighter and the
black guys
kids with a z yeah
i have a lot of friends i've known for
very very many years and all of whom are
in this business and
you know i went through a bit of a
crisis and none of them were there for
me and you know who else he's talking
about
brandon the big dog himself
that's true he's talking about rogue dog
didn't look out for him he's talking
about the big dog the king of podcasting
gino bisconti
the new king the new king
gino biscotti
pat dixon punches him off of the throne
um
[ __ ] hilarious none of them are still
there for me in any way in any capacity
whatsoever
including
jordan not limited to joe rogan brendan
shobb
theo vaughn
whitney cummings whitney cummings
more like whitney goings
[Laughter]
and
i was i was kind of like the biggest
letdown was realizing that i don't have
any friends
moment of [ __ ] self-realization there
so you're telling me you're telling me i
mean all your little la [ __ ] hipster
friends collect sneakers and weed and
aren't your buddies turns out they're
not your real friends
[Music]
ryan callan said that down was realizing
that i don't have any friends that i
don't have you're my friend i have a
friend but i'm saying
you're really rare but for the most part
there are people i've known for so long
i can't depend you know the only other
person to give him credit
that backed him up with steve burns
the asian dude from sullivan yeah he's
the because immediately he was like no
no hey hey hey come on we'll do a
podcast [ __ ] them and and to give him
credit he did do that he was like no no
hey hey
brian it's cool we'll do a podcast [ __ ]
these guys
um the only other thing a little bit
yeah even in the worst day of my life
that that i cannot i that and you have
to understand that about this business
that i i realized that i i had i don't
have a community i'd never had a
community i never comedy was not a
community comedy was the most selfish
group of people acting hollywood the
actors the writers and the directors and
the comics what
remember what basically all the
non-civilians
all the things that we told you that we
criticized when we were talking
initially about the many moons ago about
the fighter and the kid and brendan job
this is exactly what we said ago you're
all phonies none of you care about each
other you hate each other you walk over
each other in a heartbeat and then what
happened was reality hit you and they
did and they did i've always said this
even when you look back at the old stuff
even when we used to criticize
him i think brian callan can be very
funny i i really do believe that i i
mean he he has a funny guy he has good
timing and all that i also think brian
cowan's a [ __ ] hothead
and i also think brian kellen's dad was
in the cia but also like you're just
coming to realize now at this age yeah
that these [ __ ] little clicky
career-minded
snooty la
like hollywood types aren't really your
friends right right you lost your family
over this [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] good point man god
danny think about that merch good point
why don't you why didn't you just spend
more time with your family who would
have loved you why don't you
uh also what i don't understand right
i have friends i have more friends
outside of this realm of [ __ ] that we do
of course than i do inside of it as you
do
yeah so like have you thought about
getting regular friends no because you
think you're above everybody you're not
just gonna hang out with somebody who's
a systems analyst
who just works in i.t you're not gonna
have any regular friends at a bar that
you could go hang out with and have a
few drinks with you don't have that
because you wanted to play with the cool
kids and it turns out the cool kids are
never really friends
sucks doesn't it it sounds like you're
blaming them when really it's up to you
to not pursue all this empty hollywood
[ __ ] and then be disappointed that
these people really weren't really my
friends they're just out here for a
career yeah
yeah so i don't trust any of these
goddamn streamers and [ __ ] you know what
i mean you could go to the vents and
like
i could be friendly with people
but like
i'm never going to be let down that some
streamers not he wasn't really my friend
no i mean of course
that i know
were were the most selfish people on the
planet and that nobody really gives a
[ __ ] about anybody it's all about them
and yeah
i don't live that way i don't live my
life that way i never have and to my to
my shame and to my
to my uh
to
to my detriment because it was like
i always
i think life should be about teamwork i
think we should all be there for each
other i think you know teamwork makes a
dream work i just came up with that what
do you think dude why stop saying [ __ ]
like that on the air i mean it's a
patreon people they're gonna they're not
gonna steal it you're a [ __ ] idiot
dude yeah
teamwork
that's a billion dollar idea right there
teamwork makes the dream work i've never
heard every single bar manager and
restaurant manager in history write that
on a board in the back they will now now
that they've heard it
i am totally not writing this down and
sending it over hey don't do that don't
send it yeah but china would
google translate it wrong it'll come out
weird it'll be like
steam steam farts makes the street cars
or something
i think we should all be there to
support each other i think we should all
be there to [ __ ] really help each
other no matter what because that's
what's so much fun is creating a real a
real hey man
turn your phone off please you're doing
a show can you put that [ __ ] on vibrate
oh [ __ ] team like creating a real
[ __ ] why you answer that who's that
dracula cia that's my buddy
dracula
you were ending it you're wrapping it up
and i was wrapping it down went off i
probably was better i was starting to
ramble on the way i do no no it was good
but but i mean it is a heartbreak and
it's like i've never understood why
people can't understand the value of
like creating a really strong dude
circle i just want to say something
i
i want to say that
oh that's but but the clip ends um
i like on sam tripoli's own show they
clip something and as soon as sam's like
i'd like to all right we're done with
the clip